[Musique]
bonjour Lucien dazé bonjour j'ai envie
de vous recevoir vous êtes écrivez vous
parler avec vous de la balle anglaise la
belle anglaise c'est un personnage que
moi j'ai découvert je ne connaissais pas
qui s'appelle Marie Robinson qui est qui
a vécu à la fin du XVIIIe siècle en gros
entre 1750 et 1801 dans cette période là
qui est à la fois une
icône de la mode une actrice mais aussi
une écrivaine une ministre une poétesse
et alors on l'a comparé je dis ça tout
de suite à
madonnaie qu'on va on va parler d'elle
un mot peut-être sur vous vous êtes vous
êtes quelque chose vous avez écrit une
vingtaine de livres beaucoup de
traduction de l'italien et de l'anglais
des dictionnaires des dictionnaires de
Venise indicateur de Florence des
nouveaux exercices de style aussi j'ai
vu ça
et puis des livres sur la Grèce des
biographies enfin c'est une oeuvre
extrêmement
variée avec peut-être c'est pareil je
dirais une sorte d'unité qui est
peut-être la curiosité l'attirance pour
des personnages ou des lieux peu connus
et au fond vous êtes un voyageur dans
l'espace et dans le temps je dirais oui
en tout cas bon il y a plusieurs
plusieurs pays qui m'attirent depuis
toujours la l'Angleterre la l'Italie
l'Italie du Nord surtout et puis la
Grèce donc et comme je m'intéresse à la
peinture et à la littérature souvent je
me suis concentré sur des personnages
qui viennent de ces pays et notamment la
belle Anglaise qui est notamment cette
belle glace Perdita
Robinson ouvert pourquoi elle s'appelle
Perdita dans un instant vous serez vous
êtes le 19 et le 20 novembre au salon
histoire de lire de Versailles donc on
pourrait dédicacer votre ce livre
notamment
il y a
on va revenir d'ailleurs sur ce livre
parce qu'il y a plusieurs livres dans
cet ouvrage il y a une biographie mais
il y a aussi
des extraits de que vous avez trois
dites de des écrits de Marie Robinson et
puis c'est aussi un portrait de
l'Angleterre de cette fin du 18e siècle
alors il faut dire que c'est une époque
absolument incroyable quoi parce que il
y a à la fois le début de la révolution
industrielle en Angleterre la Révolution
française
ici enfin
171789 c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
époque qui vous fascine ça oui j'aime
beaucoup cette période qui va en gros de
la Révolution française on garde
napoléonienne jusqu'à la Régence
anglaise c'est-à-dire 1810 1820 et ce
qui m'intéressait donc à travers Mary
Robinson un des aspects qui
m'intéressait particulièrement c'est
qu'elle reflète en fait comme un prisme
elle reflète son pays c'est une sorte de
figure emblématique de l'Angleterre de
la deuxième partie du XVIIIe siècle à la
fois comme figure de la mode parce que
elle a d'abord été une comédienne elle
est originaire de
la période est-ce que vous auriez que
cette période où le monde bascule dans
la modernité au fond oui une certaine
façon
il va y avoir peut-être un petit retour
d'ailleurs au 19e siècle un peu plus
elle précède un peu la vous avez parlé
de la révélation industrielle on est
juste un peu avant juste avant donc elle
est dans l'air mais ça commence tout
juste les premières grandes inventions
d'une période fascinante quoi et puis
alors ce qui est intéressant pour les
Français c'est d'avoir le point de vue
des Anglais sur ce grand bouleversement
qui a été la Révolution française qui a
d'abord été très perçu comme comme une
un grand progrès pour les Britanniques
avant-gardiste
progressiste et puis ensuite il y a eu
un retour
très violent conservateur de
l'Angleterre qui a été terrorisée et
traumatisée par la terreur c'est une
période
où tous les regards se tournent vers la
France quand même de l'Europe la France
devient le grand modèle et ensuite la
Révolution française a inspiré de
nombreuses révolutions à travers le
monde a commencé par la révolution russe
mais c'est un événement qui est regardé
de très près par
la presse britannique parce que c'est
vraiment le mot est pris à la lettre le
mode révolution est pris à la lettre à
ce moment-là c'est le monde qui va être
bouleversé alors parlons de de la belle
anglaise de Marie Perdita Robinson on
peut dire tout de suite pourquoi elle
s'appelle Perdita vous le disiez elle a
été actrice oui elle a commencé donc
elle était originaire de Bristol elle
arrivait assez jeune à Londres vers 20
ans et elle a eu elle a commencé par
avoir une très belle carrière de médiane
elle a joué dans les principautés de
Londres Drarry Line et Covent Garden et
elle a joué à interprété une centaine de
rôles dont assez souvent le rôle de
Perdita dans le conte d'hiver de
Shakespeare et donc elle a on lui a
donné ce surnom parce qu'on la voyait
souvent interpréter sur alors le but je
vais vous citer à peu près pour traiter
très très rapidement marée Robinson vous
dites elle est contemporaine de Mozart
et de Marie-Antoinette elle fut une
comédienne talentueuse une cortisane
célèbre une icône de la mode une
écrivaine accomplie et produite auteur
de 7 romans une démocrate une féministe
engagée une amende passionnée une
hôtesse généreuse charmante et
spirituelle une fille et une mère
dévouée charitable sensible piquante et
parfois difficile en raison de son
handicap va y venir il est arrivé qu'on
la compare à Marie-Madeleine et aussi à
Madonna oui j'ai pris l'exemple de
Madonna pour donner pour qu'on mesure ça
notoriété même si elle n'a pas été très
longue en fait elle a une vie courte
elle est morte à 43 ans donc elle était
de 1757 elle est morte avec le début du
19e elle est morte en 1800 et elle a
elle a triomphé
au début des années 80 et notamment
comme alors comme comédienne mais
surtout comme égérie de la mode
absolument
les aristocrates mais aussi par la
peinture oui et les grands peintres
choisissaient des modèles pour leur
beauté pour leur allure souvent les
modèles n'avaient pas les moyens
d'acheter des tableaux à moins qu'un
mécène les achètent et Marie Robinson a
posé pour les plus grands peintres
anglais de l'époque donc
Joshua Reynolds Thomas kenboro
revenait aussi pour John opener et
d'ailleurs on a reproduit dans le livre
les principaux
plus de 8 portraits sont reproduits
reproduits dans le livre et à travers
ces portraits donc elle est devenue très
célèbre parce que les portraits étaient
copiés il y avait des gravures qui
circulaient et ils étaient aussi exposés
dans les ateliers des peintres Reynolds
qui habitait à laisser square avait un
atelier où il mettait il gardait les
principaux portraits d'abord pour pour
encourager des mécènes à se faire faire
leur portrait et puis les gens venaient
regarder donc ces tableaux
en tout cas c'était un écran et Marie
Robinson a tout de suite connu une très
grande popularité ça c'est la première
chose qui a construit une question quand
même parce que
[Musique]
on mettait comme comme titre comme
cartel anglaise à la campagne
et puis on a redécouvert ses écrits et
on avait découvert aussi toute sa toute
sa carrière et c'est comme ça que je
l'ai rencontré parce qu'elle était
elle était elle est mentionnée par des
écrivains que j'ai traduit ou par
exemple au Woody à ma vie tu parles
assez fascinant c'est assez c'est assez
étonnant enfin alors vous dites c'est
pas tout à fait pareil en Angleterre et
en France en France
et ses œuvres ont été alors certaines
ces romans ont été traduits sur le
moment
donc peu après leur parution on trouve
toujours le biotechnal des éditions
d'époque
mais depuis
il n'y a plus rien donc j'ai choisi
parce que je voulais absolument lui
donner sa voix c'est un livre qui qui
pour moitié est une biographie
il y a une biographie de ça commence par
une biographie alors on peut en parler
elle est né à Bristol donc d'un père qui
était quoi avocat marchand c'est un
aventurier
intéressant
qui est assez emblématique de Bristol
est une ville importante c'était la
deuxième ville d'Angleterre à l'époque
c'était le port le plus important qui
s'est enrichi comme Nantes en France à
cause de la de l'esclavage c'était le
port par excellence du commerce
triangulaire et puis ensuite il était
supplanté par Liverpool parce qu'on
estimait que la la route qui menait aux
États-Unis ou en dehors de l'Irlande
était plus sûr
mais à ce moment là c'est une ville très
importante d'ailleurs Stevenson situe
l'île au trésor à Bristol au début et ça
se passe en 1750 donc à la période où
est né Marie Robinson et c'est très
important il décrit des personnages
comme son père qui donne aventurier
voilà qui a qui a traité des bateaux qui
passent la fortune voilà c'est ça ils
s'embarque dans les aventures très
dangereux il est devenu ensuite corsaire
il a fini sa carrière au service de la
Russie
alors elle se marie avec un type peintre
monsieur Robinson
qui est pas un titre très recommandable
alors elle se marie avec un jeune homme
qui est qui est avocat enfin il n'a pas
tout à fait fils ni ses études il est
joueur et qui
très vite va la négliger en tout cas
c'était important pour elle d'être marié
c'est une sorte de protection
va rester avec elle jusqu'à la fin de
cette journée
veut dire qu'elle était une mère très
très attentionnée à l'égard de sa fille
alors donc voilà donc on l'a dit un peu
elle devient d'abord et gérer de la mode
elle devient ensuite comédienne David
Garry c'est un des plus grands comédiens
de l'époque elle est vraiment été formée
par un très grand metteur en scène et
elle devient aussi à menthe oui et
notamment alors d'un personnage qui est
assez particulier aussi qui est le futur
George IV qui est le prince de Galles
quel futur Georges IV qui a un
personnage
sans doute oublié alors que il y a une
vie absolument incroyable vous avez
voulu pas voir sa femme il s'est marié
en secret avec une catholique enfin
dépensier
il est dansait tout à l'heure à tel
point que voilà le même le surveillé
dans le dans le royaume quoi c'est et
puis il y avait beaucoup de maîtresse
quoi il avait beaucoup de maîtresses
c'est marrer Robinson était sa première
médecin
en fait elle le rencontre lors d'un
spectacle privé ou elle interprète
justement Perdita et à un spectacle
était réservé à la famille royale et le
Prince de Galles à l'époque avait
seulement 17 ans il avait 5 ans - elle
il va tomber amoureux de de la
comédienne et
la liaison va devenir de notoriété
publique donc les journaux vont en
parler connu pour ça voilà
jusqu'à la fin du siècle même après
cette liaison va durer à peine un an
mais on va continuer d'en parler il y a
eu beaucoup de caricatures et donc c'est
ce qui a ce qui a le plus fait par les
d'ailleurs elle en a tiré parti par la
suite dans ses romans parce que elle est
laissée entendre même si c'était pas
vrai qu'elle révélait des secrets sur
sur sa liaison avec le prince de Galles
alors à d'autres liaisons ceci
elle est
la famille royale a voulu que ça ne
correspondance reste
secrète et du coup elle a été indemnisée
assez
pour vous dire l'important ce que ça
représentait parce que la espérée être
la maîtresse en titre du prince de
Galles elle a renoncé quand même à sa
carrière de comédienne pour se consacrer
au prince de Galles même si ça n'a pas
duré longtemps et ensuite à la monnayer
d'une forme de champion voilà elle
possédait l'aide compromettante et elle
a réussi à obtenir une pension que que
le prince de Galles lui versait
irrégulièrement mais qui lui a tout de
même permis de vivre pendant un certain
temps parce qu'elle est elle-même était
très dépensière
non seulement pour pour les tenues quel
HTM elle avait une passion aussi pour
des véhicules notamment un véhicule qui
s'appelle le feuilleton une espèce de
cabriolet très rapide et elle dépensait
beaucoup d'argent elle avait un train de
vie et elle a réussi à avoir une pension
qui correspondait à peu près à 60 000
euros par an ce qui nous permet
c'est c'est pas si mal ça a été le grand
amour de sa vie je prends le prince de
garde non elle a alors elle a elle a eu
ce qu'elle a eu d'autres elle a eu
d'autres liaisons mais le grand amour de
sa vie c'est un héros de la de la Garde
indépendance américaine à la guerre d'un
avance des États-Unis qui s'appelait
ballaston qui était colonel donc
britannique et qui au retour donc après
la la fin de la guerre vers
1782 il revient en Angleterre il est
acclamé parce que c'est un des grands et
gros il était passé pour il passait pour
un gros sanglant et il va être pas en
même temps qu'elle par Joshua Reynolds
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure et c'est
comme ça qu'elle va le rencontrer dans
l'atelier de rénovs et là c'est une
vraie passion à la fois physique et une
espèce de complicité va naître entre eux
même s'ils sont ils ont des
appartiennent à des camps politiques
très différents
qui appartient à une famille
d'esclavagistes de Liverpool est un
homme de droite conservateur et elle est
révolutionnaire
mais
c'est une femme augure
c'est une femme de gauche et leur
liaison donc parmi toutes les tous les
éléments
tous les paramètres qui les liait elle a
elle a beaucoup écrit pour lui elle lui
écrit elle écrit les mémoires
et elle écrivait ses discours par la
suite il est devenu député elle écrivait
comme Colette
et c'était avant tout un rapport
passionnel vous disiez qu'elle était
contemporaine de Marie-Antoinette la
rencontrer elle l'a rencontré elle était
elles avaient le même âge exactement et
Marie Robinson est venu plusieurs fois
en France mais elle est venue avant la
Révolution en 1782
et elle connaissait le duc d'Orléans qui
lui a permis de d'être invité ce qui lui
a permis d'être invité au grand souper à
Versailles et elle a rencontré
Marie-Antoinette qui avait été charmée
par sa beauté et qui lui avait demandé
d'ailleurs de lui prêter un médaillon du
prince de Galles que Marie Robinson
Portet et elle lui a offert une
maille-antoinette mais beaucoup la
broderie la couture elle lui offert une
petite bourse qu'elle avait confectionné
elle-même donc il y a elle se sent
rencontrées une fois puis par la suite
Marie Robinson a rencontré la grande
couturière de Marie-Antoinette et elle a
rapporté en Angleterre des robes qui ont
qui ont fait fureur qui ont eu beaucoup
de succès alors il y a
quelque chose qui est très important
parce que ça explique peut-être la
deuxième partie de la vie de Mario
Winston c'est un accident qui va la
handicaper alors
un jour donc elle avait cette liaison
passionnelle avec Talton que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure qui était lui aussi un
joueur et il va être obligé de quitter
l'Angleterre à un moment donné parce que
il risque la prison Bourdette et
l'échappatoire la plus classique c'était
la France mais avant la Révolution donc
on est en 1783 et à ce soir il disparaît
un soir où elle espérait elle voit le
retrouver après un spectacle et elle va
courir à bord de son feuilleton elle va
elle va partir à Douvres un soir d'été
alors qu'elle est enceinte de trois mois
et elle a un accident probablement alors
c'est difficile de reconstituer mais
c'est probablement une fausse couche
avec des complications qui vont se
traduire par de l'arthrose des
rhumatismes aigus et c'est compliqué
vont très vite
l'handicapé de plus en plus elle va ta
deuxième partie de sa vie
elle ne peut plus marcher elle va même
perdre l'usage de de ses doigts et elle
mourra des conséquences
elle avait 25 ans à l'époque donc elle a
survécu 18 ans à
mais ça la ça la conduite ensuite à
conduite aussi à changer sa vie c'est à
dire que de
comédienne est déjà et de la mode elle
devient écrivaine donc écrit cette roman
c'est ça c'est ça elle ne pouvait donc
elle ne pouvait plus jouer de toute
façon elle avait déjà renoncé à sa
carrière de comédienne mais elle va elle
va devenir moins mondaine elle sera
transportée d'ailleurs à certaines
réceptions par des porteurs et puis elle
va fréquenter aussi les lieux les
établissements thermaux aussi bien en
Angleterre un Brighton par exemple qu'en
Europe et elle va se mettre à écrire
d'abord des poèmes alors on avait déjà
écrit dans sa jeunesse mais là elle va
écrire des poèmes et puis très vite elle
va alors
dans ce livre je voulais lui donner la
voix à la fin du livre donc il y a une
petite anthologie absolument où j'ai
traduit des fragments de ces remords
traduire certains de ses poèmes et puis
aussi une un pamphlet qu'elle est écrit
enfin une lettre d'Angleterre
les romans ils ont bien marché alors les
romans ont bien marché parce que comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure elle a tiré
partie de sa notoriété donc c'était une
star quoi c'était une star et beaucoup
de gens ont acheté les livres parce que
ils espèrent découvrir des détails
croustillants sur les liaisons qu'elle
avait eu et ce sont des romans qui sont
dans le goût de l'époque alors il y a la
fois des romans gothiques c'était Andre
Cliff la
écrivaine de l'époque donc un peu à la
manière d'un Red Cliff dans ces moquée
par la suite diagnostic et puis des
romans et pistolaires
elle a même fait un roman qui se passe
pendant la Révolution française qui
s'appelle le père de servac et elle
raconte et péripéties d'analystocrate
qui est pour la révolution mais qui
obligeait de quitter la France ça gagne
bien
un écrivain cette époque là oui alors
elle a ce qui est intéressant je me suis
attardé dans le livre c'est ça dépend du
type de contrat les éditeurs qui étaient
des libraires les professions se
confondaient à l'époque vous proposez
soit de payer les livres et de vous
débrouiller pour les vendre soit de
prendre en charge
le coût de l'édition alors évidemment
elle a eu différents types de contrats
mais elle a gagné de l'argent alors elle
s'occupait vraiment de la promotion de
ces livres au point qu'elle écrivait des
articles dans les journaux sous des
pseudonymes où elle faisait elle faisait
les loges des livres
elle avait alors elle a utilisé aussi
une autre méthode
qui était la méthode des encyclopédistes
elle a utilisé la souscription elle a
publié par exemple ses recueil de poèmes
par souscription elle réussissait à
réunir jusqu'à 500 personnes ce qui
était qui avançaient donc l'argent alors
un mot sur ce sur ce ce cette lettre
féministe qui est une lettre sur
l'injustice de la subordination
intellectuelle des femmes c'est ça
oui donc c'est une
un discours féministe enfin alors il y
avait déjà il y a plusieurs anglaises
avec des écrits ce genre de lettre la
plus connue c'est Marie Winston kraft
qui est la mère de Marie Shelley et qui
a le même âge que Marie Robinson mais
qui va qui va mourir
à la suite de quand elle donne des sens
justement à maréchallais quelques jours
après
elle met en pratiquement en couche en
1797 elle avait déjà écrit une lettre
féministe et Marie Robinson qui la
connaissait qu'il avait fréquenté par
l'intermédiaire de son compagnon William
Godwin
a écrit donc cette lettre qui est très
belle et qui mériterait d'être publiée
en entier en France il n'y a pas
d'édition française
où elle prend la défense des femmes et
elle se plaint surtout de tous les
privilèges
qu'on les hommes et par exemple je
citais les discours écrivait les
discours de son compagnon de Tarleton
pour la
pour la Chambre des députés la Chambre
des lords et elle n'avait pas le droit
d'y assister
c'est un
pamphlet oui enfin un engagement en tout
cas féministe
elle était connue comme féministe ou pas
vraiment sur le moment elle était connue
mais après il faut voir qu'il y a
cette époque était rejeté assez vite par
déjà par la raison par la Régence
anglaise et ensuite par le victorianisme
il y a eu un véritable rejet de ces
femmes émanciper libérées de la femme du
18e siècle alors c'est une vie
évidemment on a un peu raconté mais
enfin il faut aller dans le livre pour
avoir beaucoup plus de d'histoire parce
que c'est une vie absolument incroyable
qu'est-ce que vous vous retenez d'elle
au fond si vous deviez la définir c'est
moi ce qui m'intéressait en particulier
et c'est sa polyvalence c'est le fait
que elle a un talent multiple donc elle
est une excellente comédienne
pareil aussi qu'elle chantait très bien
c'est une vraiment un personnage qui qui
a une allure naturelle donc au point de
devenir plus qu'un mannequin puisqu'elle
pose pour les peintres ensuite elle
devient écrivaine elle est capable de de
s'engager politiquement elle suit de
très près d'actualité et à côté de ça
une vie privée tout à fait passionnante
amoureuse mais en même temps c'est une
une grande hôtesse aussi elle recevait
souvent elle a passé la fin de sa vie à
côté de windsa dans un petit une petite
chaumière et quoi qu'un valide elle
continuait de recevoir des gens et il y
a quelque chose de très bienveillant de
très plaisant chez elle j'aurais pu
tomber amoureux d'elle
je pense que j'aurais été ébloui par on
va très bien à travers ses portraits
elle devait avoir un très grand charisme
en tout cas c'est un livre absolument
encore une fois il y a là il y a la il y
a trois livres on pourrait dire c'est ça
donc la moitié du livre c'est une
biographie et tout autour j'ai greffé
des des éléments littéraires alors il y
a des notices
aussi je me mets voilà à sa place de
temps en temps
ou je deviens Marie Robinson et puis
donc une anthologie où je la fais parler
il y a des de bref
essaient d'histoire de l'art où je
décrypte les tableaux et je parle d'une
manière iconographique de chacun de ces
tableaux mais j'explique aussi les
rapports qu'elle entretenait avec les
peintres et il dénotise aussi sur des
accessoires par exemple sur on en a pas
parlé mais elle elle recourait à l'opium
enfin au lot d'un homme pour pour aller
chez ses souffrances et donc il y a une
notice sur sur
fascinant ça va être donc la belle
anglaise vide bernita Robinson et c'est
aux édition des belles lettres et puis
je rappelle que vous êtes au Salon du
livre de Versailles samedi 19 et
dimanche 20 novembre merci beaucoup
Luciennes merci beaucoup de m'avoir
invité
[Musique]